[Music]
do any of you guys follow Kylie Jenner
no I never know one that's a billionaire
with the lips got it yeah I don't know
well that's very very different than
what she naturally looks like yeah okay
well she posted stuff on her Instagram
stop eating she's done now they're both
they're done I feel like the teacher you
know when the teacher goes okay well
we're all cut wait until so-and-so is
done with the so-and-so things that's
happening but they didn't have an
audience of like a hundred thousand
people who are wait exactly you're
literally making this always my every
time we turn the camera on Nikki's like
better take a sip better have a snack
better place the mischief table okay oh
really is it drives me crazy that's why
I ignore this table anyway so Kelli
dinner that's we're talking about so she
posted a whole bunch of photos of her
and her sister and this is Kylie this is
Kendall and they stretch that leg yeah
they did mm-hmm and people that are
weird decided to do this and zoom in
added a toe Oh her middle toe is really
sure yeah zoom in and our middle toe yes
there's no way that's real because Kylie
Jenner of all people would have edited
that out before she posted she will
shoot away another foot is normal I
think it's just the angle of the toe it
might be curved up okay like like as
since it's in here it could be just like
it curled a little yeah well what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this way I know I
know
guys slow news day we can't talk about
karana that much because we monetize our
wiki feat people stole all the words
that I'm with you girl I got your back
over a one short toe hey come at us bro
we can't talk about Corona because of
Susan wants Chucky you you can't even
Chucky
stop saying it I'll say what seconds
much as I want okay so then Kylie ended
up posting this weird ass video
explaining what's wrong with her toe
yes for instance to come from my [ __ ]
toes why do I have to dust feet and I
broke this middle toe in middle school
and you can't really there's nothing you
do for a broken toe so I just have to
let it heal how it wanted to heal so
when I flex this up right when I like
flex it at all this is a weird ass you
can see it better when I'm standing so
when I flex this up there on door mall
and like in place the middle toe focus
on the middle toe and then when I flex
this up this little guy just like is out
of place the wiki feet people are so
happy yeah yeah you just got a net girls
and they'll [ __ ] give you feet videos
Jesus did she get paid for that was that
one only fans or was that no but she
ends up like dragging her sister because
she's like I'm sorry what cuz uh Kendall
this is her toes I mean you just hanging
off the edge she owes the world an
explanation
I totally dropped that toes my dream
toenail polish all night yes that shows
like a [ __ ] like like the Rockefeller
dancers man like that [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
of it yeah that was a person at first
and then my headline guys yeah of course
it did yeah I'm so glad I know about
this now me too I wanna sleep properly
god bless oh my god but can you imagine
being that famous and you're just trying
to live your life and somebody just
tears you down like all the time comes
for your toes I know for any little room
man they zoom always eat that money I
will just embrace my weird I'll be that
that's famous person that baddest
notorious for like taking shits in
public
losing coupons at Target well you're so
famous why you stop at Target like bits
because I like the Goodfellas clothes I
like these clothes man like these plain
white t-shirts that's I know that
homeless guy who's famous for taking
shits in public oh yeah that's what
you're going for me yeah yeah oh my man
[ __ ] it I wonder if she did that as like
a little teaser or something for like
her only fans like four feet or
something like see that right there we
just for free was that no I was just
wondering if she did like our keys or
something that would be like she was
about to just like release like a bunch
of like oh god this is a bad week for me
to make that joke in the first place
[ __ ] I went to the press I went to
the toe salon the other day I'm tired oh
it's a nail salon and it was right after
a meditation class about happiness and
so I'm all in my head about like
happiness joy love so when I go in I
pick out this bottle that's like a nice
pretty yellow I'm like it reminds me of
the Sun and then they put it on my toes
and I was like I look like I have
jaundice and she was like you like it
yes she was like you like it right and I
would say well we could do another code
and she was like okay and then she just
left spine would be like please help me
so I look like a red jaundice on my toes
I'm like I don't see the jaundice I see
only fans opportunity sorry those have a
restaurant yeah no I'm saying that I
accidentally showed my your husband my
foot oh oh yeah it's very turned on but
I'm really in defeated [ __ ] up for free
we could have been making money off and
I know but they didn't see the front of
the tub they didn't see the front not
everybody's out for the shoals they
always asked for souls anyone is
scrunched up [ __ ] you want scrunched up
that's right alright somebody asked me
for a bear paw it's like the souls but
you throw your toes in
thank you nothing you guys speaking of
toes my both of my big toe toenails
[ __ ] up we have to what do you mean
you liar
I think I've no I'm not proving it if
you guys want it uh venmo me $150 and
I'll get some pictures
hey I'm worth more than over that cheap
bit so I'm not the whole not the whole
foot just a big toe Bret Oh baby
remember when we went to the moon rock
concert do you recall that that the
whole day I was at Disneyland
mm-hm well I was I was at Disneyland and
afterwards we went to the monarch
concert all day I was wearing these
shoes that fit me a little too small and
my big toenails were a little too long
and so all day my nail was hitting up
against the tip thingy of what is this
called tipping your toe yeah what is it
the tip of the shoe and it was like a
hard whole box is over come on oh it's
kind of like Nicki's shoot like the
clunkers like where it's like harder and
the tip yellows 15 hey they're signed by
a sugarcoat those is you a 15 in real
life yeah real life in real life well
yeah so because of that anyway my my
toes got a lot of trauma to the point
where it was like dried blood under
there and recently I was way too
embarrassed to go to the slope at the
toe salon to get some big or so then I
did it myself I actually ordered one of
the the hand thingies
what are like with you were to get a
motorized trimmer for your toning yes
the motorized trimmer a dremel a lot one
of those you know you're one of those
people who cleans for maids yeah you
cleaned before the maid comes oh no
that's okay you should tidy you should
tidy [ __ ] and cleaning are two
separate oh so I did it myself and then
I kind of went a little too cool
I prefer my because I started on my
right one which is the more [ __ ] up
one because it's already lifted like my
entire show just ooze ready dried blood
this is like months ago it was in
September and I just did this like two
weeks ago
c'mon dude I don't want to see it
obviously we didn't I went a little too
crazy right to the point where the nail
was like it was gone so my right toe big
toe now it has no nail and I ended up
just painting tonal toenail what the
[ __ ] no holy Sh yeah well are you guys
okay
yeah this is what I ever saw at the end
of the day as you can see I get largest
foot fetish torture for the left I even
learned my lesson from the right so then
I didn't go too crazy so I still have a
nail but it's like paper thin it's about
to fall off well you should have kept in
law and that's what I like to do when
somebody makes me mad I just threaten to
like swipe them with my foot when your
toenails along there you go
just do a little round house what you
mean just just go to the nail salon
they've seen worse now I have no nail
they'll talk [ __ ] on you in a different
language if we find it we'll take care
of you here fine dude yes I did my own
and then because I'm not skilled in nail
polish in their [ __ ] up why did you
buy a buffer for it why did you buy that
what oh they were too long at that point
oh because I had the hard hard gel on I
had hard gel on the nail so I had the
remote so I could paint in different
colors I could fix it somehow that's
what happens well you should look at the
manscape trimmer with
[Laughter]
we stay on topic it's still about toes
Hey Oh bro last time I was getting out
last time but while ago I was getting a
pedicure and I don't I don't ask them to
scrub my feet because my feet are very
ticklish like I'll start kicking it [ __ ]
real fast
absolutely alcohol Wow Co L deep but she
I always ask them not to do like a
full-on scrub rub or whatever and then
like this time that I actually went in
she I was like oh no you don't have to
do that and she was so she's like you
need no consent no good no consent and I
was like it was for the best that was it
yeah I mean man I'm so upset she's alive
and she's fine I didn't have to know I
mean I got the full-on disclaimer dude
like do not tickle me don't do y'all not
start flailing and [ __ ] I don't like
being tickled
I get violated I will kick the [ __ ] out
of you dude I don't know buddy it got to
the point where cuz I was told that
tickling is all in your head so like it
got to the point where I could control
it and I don't get tickles I could until
I get like really giggly like like if
Steve's flirting and like he's already
making me like jiggly the only when they
kiss your neck he's like I'm ticklish
but I tried convincing Nikki for like
the first six months of our relationship
that I wasn't ticklish I didn't buy it
was like stick it hard when she was
trying to tickle me the same by it at
all I kept going you didn't know that
she kept going oh dude you should do
competitive tickling if you really know
I'm really good actually
oh I don't wanna I don't wanna you can
make a lot of money doing that [ __ ]
there's a prize pool regular guys doing
regular things up at that and you ain't
boogers on somebody else or you talking
about what are you talking about you
eating boogers yeah
difference if somebody could jerk off to
me in burgers then it's literally just
take your fine do you have any tattoos
or anything no no that's totally clean
I'm very cool I'm very cool yeah you
should definitely try it
competitive tickling okay never
[Music]
you